哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天邀請的大來賓是
我非常喜歡的賴芳玉律師
哈囉慕姿 還有
各位聽眾朋友大家好
哈哈哈哈
就是跟賴律師真的好久不見了
那覺得怎麼辦
我都看你是從小看到
長大的一個孩子一樣
所以我有點對他的發展
我有點與有榮焉
不知道在什麼心情
但是那個因為今天
剛好有機會就是
賴律師給我就是您
就是兒子的
這可以講嗎
可以講
今天剛好就是
賴律師給我送給我
就是您兒子結婚的禮物
我感覺也是非常的
因為當初我還是那邊
的輔導老師的時候
然後就是
您兒子是我的學生然後
結果太驚訝
結果他已經結婚了
他結婚了
然後我把它當作
聖誕禮物送給了慕姿
因為現在錄影
跟錄音的時間剛好是聖誕節
真的是一個
非常非常好的時間
然後剛好就可以跟賴律師相聚
而且還有一件非常重要的事情
就是賴律師出書了
《不將就的勇氣》
當然啦
就是只有出書
賴律師才可以來嗎
並不是
但是我們的確是
因為有這個機會
可以請賴律師上節目
然後我覺得這本書啊
其實本來是想跟
賴律師先聊一些
有的沒的
可是我覺得這本書實在是有
太多可以聊的
所以我想要先從這本書開始
因為我在看這本書的時候
其實這本書是
賴律師就是集結了很多
自己在就是家事的一些經驗中
對 30年的經驗
然後有一些沈澱
對
然後我看了賴律師
在寫這本書的時候
也是有就是四個階段
對
然後這四個階段中
每一個階段都還有一些故事
然後這些故事
其實有很多的探索
那個探索除了是這個當事人
自己的探索之外
還包含了我們對
我們的文化的探索
然後 我們對
我們在婚姻裡面
我們是怎麼看待婚姻的
以及世代變化那個婚姻
對婚姻制度的改變的這些東西
我看了超有感覺
因為比如說第一個我看到就是
那個賴律師寫到就是
媽媽以前是童養媳
然後後來雖然就是
有機會可以掙脫
童養媳這一個就是
桎梏
但是最後呢
他還是會掉進另外一個桎梏裡
就是必須要不停的去
得到原生家庭的
那個就是愛啊肯定啊這些東西
賴律師覺得可以分享一下這個
我坦白說就是說
我從我小時候
我就看我媽媽
怎麼一天到晚都在哭
然後
我知道他有個大溪的家
就是農村
我非常喜歡那個地方
那有一個是在
桃園的另外一個家
那那個家其實
家世背景是挺好的
所以對他來講是
一個很大的衝突
他是一個長女
然後很小的時候就被
當童養媳出養到的
大溪這個農村的子弟
然後就要照顧
很多的弟弟妹妹們
所以導致他
沒有辦法享有原生家庭
原先家庭是
好的一個資源之外
他也因此可能念書
就比較可惜一點
然後因為他照顧很多弟弟妹妹
所以永遠在廚房大灶在那邊煮菜
然後照顧這些孩子們
所以那時候我只看到媽媽
不斷的在一個創傷反應
我用回頭來看這句話的話
因為他一直很希望
原生家庭能夠認可他
他不僅是希望他
爸爸媽媽認可他
他也希望他的手足們也認可他
在這個過程當中
的認可過程當中
他永遠在哭泣
然後會模仿他們的生活習慣
用他們的對話
但我總是覺得他
好像是一直很失落
所以我從小到大
就一直看到母親
的這一幕到現在
到如今我跟他通電話
他講到這一段還是哭
所以我那時候在看我母親
對待愛跟婚姻這件事情
尤其是婚姻
童養媳的本身
你會發現有個文化認同
所以他有兩件事情
但那個文化認同在
我們那個上一代
我的媽媽那一代
你知道賢妻良母
好女人是一個非常
在道德觀裡面
其實鎖得非常緊
的一個一群女性
那我覺得他有一個很大的勇氣
他有個叛逆是
他可以逃出他原先
被安排好的生活
包括他本來被出養
你本來就童養媳
應該原生家庭不該你的事了吧
但是他就一直還是要追回去
還有包括他被安排好
是跟舅舅結婚
但他沒有 就跟我爸爸
是一個彰化來的一個小伙子
也是一個離鄉背景的一個孩子
這裡頭都有個自由這個味道
自主跟自由的味道
在他身上裡面
他講不出這個東西
但是他一直用行動在說
我想要證明我自己
我想要知道我自己
所以他不斷的要
展現他的主體性
可是我覺得他是挫敗的
他只有在我爸這邊成功了
因為我爸到現在還是很疼他
那很讚
至少有嘛
但我也必須講
我非常喜歡我的阿嬤
我大溪的阿嬤
還有那些他的手足
在大溪的手足
我意思說這麼
愛你的大溪的養父母
還有這麼愛你的父親
你為什麼還要哭呢
你為什麼還是追求原生家庭
應該講本生家庭裡面對你的
當時的遺棄
還有你為什麼會被出養的答案
你為什麼要追尋別人的眼光
我覺得他
他就永遠在那邊挫敗
所以
我會看到一件事情
那個年代的女性
她不僅僅是有自己想長出來的
但是她不斷被文化給打趴
因為男尊女卑
這件事情同樣習的文化歷史
脈絡對一個女人的一個
一個枷鎖吧
我覺得是枷鎖
就是說你會不會有一個
可能性是逃出來的時候
你覺得雖然別人可能認為
他不是一個乖孩子
但還是希望
你本身父母親是可以認可你
我不知道那個認可
到底有多重的
什麼樣的一個意義在他身上
一輩子他現在85歲了
可以長達你80
幾歲的一個年紀當中
永遠還是沒有忘
這點我當然是非常好奇
這也是觸發我走到
性別運動的一個
很重要的一個議題
因為
他代表了大部分上
一代的女人的哭泣
他也代表了我們這一代
我這個中生代 是慕姿的上一代
我們是三代
但我們中生代
我們的那個遺毒
文化遺毒 女性的文化遺毒
在我們身上就長出了什麼
我也會不斷的探索這件事情
所以
不僅是在我身上
我在我好多的個案身上
其實都看到我媽的影子
嗯
我聽賴律師在講這段的時候
非常有感覺
我覺得那個不甘願很深
就是對我現在被愛
對我現在擁有
可能不一定別人有的東西
我如果好好過現在的話
我也是幸福的
可我就不甘願
為什麼那個時候
我是被送出去的那一個
你們不要我
為什麼到底為什麼
那個答案是什麼
然後我覺得那個糾結
對於就是
我覺得賴律師講的很深刻
就是對於那個年代
的很多女性來說
自己不是那個被選擇的那個
常常在很多原因
他是被犧牲的那一個
那個不甘願
我也沒有比較不好
所以我要證明給你看
我沒有比較不好
可是我卻是那個
不被選的那一個
那個內心的
創傷跟痛楚
我既要做我的自由
我想要做到的事情
去證明我很好
但另外一方面
我要證明我很好
我要有那個對象
所以你要覺得我很好
所以我又要努力的去順著
你的價值觀
去勉強自己做到一些
你希望我做到的事情
我覺得這個掙扎性其實
很明顯
因為我媽媽也是一個
這樣在這樣子的狀況長大的人
而且因為我外公是日本人
但是我的繼外公是榮民
所以在這樣子
因為後來我的外公是過世的
所以他在這樣子的狀態之下
他其實面臨到更多的
因為文化差異
還有男尊女卑所造成的一些
就是受傷
甚至不被重視等等
但是我覺得這件事情
對我的文化影響也很大
就是剛剛我在跟賴律師聊到
賴律師在說媽媽她
很希望得到肯定
然後我就一直在想
因為我在自己的工作上
也常常遇到有很多人
不管是男生也好 女生也好
很希望就算現在表現得再好
就是很需要父母的肯定
包含歐文·亞隆
也有寫到這個東西
就是我們很需要
那個父母的肯定
可是已經這麼多年了
也有包含李安也有講到嘛
就是這麼多年了
你有表現那麼好
父母的肯定
為什麼對你那麼重要
然後我就發現那個好像真的是
一個從小的一個劇本
那個創傷劇本
我沒有的劇本
那個匱乏的劇本
一直都沒有完成
然後我就想到我小時候
我發現我沒有很需要
我媽媽的肯定
我其實想過這件事
因為我想說
我也是一個很在乎
就是我有沒有把事情做好
讓我媽媽就是
覺得我媽媽以我為榮這種
可是為什麼我沒有很需要
我媽媽的肯定
然後我就一直在想
然後我就發現沒有
我需要的不是
我媽媽以我為榮
我需要的是我把事情做好之後
別人以我媽媽為榮
別人說我媽媽做超好
別人說哎呦
周慕姿這麼好
就是因為
哦 你好會教哦
你好棒哦
就是這樣我就覺得我完成了
我覺得慕姿這一段還蠻動人的
因為我覺得能夠去剝離出
我到底在尋求什麼樣的認可
這個目標性的東西
沒有幾個人會釐清哦
我想有幾個
我想跟慕姿分享
還有聽眾分享就是
尋求認可這一件事情
在我們
我不知道是不是
在我們生存裡面
是一個很重要的核心價值
好
那如果你在加上的一個文化
性別文化這件事情
那個認可裡面
一定會到變成整個社會當中
或這個世代跟這個文化
怎麼認可我
好 除了我自我認可之外
也包括這整個社會認可
但是在社會認可之前
我還有一個門檻就是
這個原生家庭
這個父母到底有沒有認可我
他似乎一直讓我們
每天到你幾歲
不管你現在幾歲
你都在尋求認可
你再小你也想要
哦 看到媽媽這樣鼓勵你
哦 你好棒哦
這樣子之類的哦
所以我不知道在
這個尋求認可的一個
勾勾裡面
我想要請教慕姿的事
這樣這樣勾勾裡面
我們其實明白
這個勾勾像一個紅蘿蔔似的
是一個像一個迷幻藥似的
一直勾著我們往那個方向走
可是我們明明想要做自己
想要做自己想做的事
意思我不要大半輩子都在
服務你的
服務你的榮耀嘛
譬如是慕姿想要
榮耀自己的母親哦
那我沒有
我當我看到這件事情的時候
你會不會在過度努力
當然這是慕姿很重要的一個
一本書跟歷程
他取這個書名真的太棒了
他到底為什麼可以讓你過度
過度就是指說
我已經超越我必須做的事情
去服務別人對我的理解
所以我看到尤其律師醫師
很多的精英
這一件事情如此的清清楚楚
擺在那裡說我需要
得到尤其是醫生
我需要我爸爸媽媽
肯定我唸醫學院
可是我事實上想要去畫畫
我想要去彈鋼琴
就像慕姿想要去唱歌
可是他也是當了心理師
就是說你有很多自己
想要走的人生軌跡
可是當你要尋求
父母認可的時候
我媽媽而言就是養父母
跟他的本身父母
都有對他有期待
那你做不到這個期待的時候
你想聽到哪一句話
除了你講很棒你就講真的嗎
你真的覺得我很棒嗎
好像永遠都不夠
所以我們到底要
在這裡頭如何去
在這裡頭為自己踩煞車呢
我覺得賴律師你真的是
沒來念諮商真的太可惜
雖然我覺得法律這個部分
對你也是很重要
就是我覺得這一個
東西非常非常的
直
就是非常直觀
然後我覺得非常的就是直戳到
那個很重要的部分
就是明明知道這個是紅蘿蔔
然後到了一個年紀之後
你還是追求一個你內心那個
曾經匱乏過的
那一個認可
那個認可為什麼這麼勾住我們
就比如說我剛剛說就是
每個人都需要肯定我也需要
我的肯定常常都是
這個肯定可以回過頭來讓我
媽媽覺得很開心
讓我媽媽覺得
哦他去
那個別的地方就別人會跟他說
哎呦你們家慕姿好棒哦
然後還沒有啦沒有啦
就是要演完這一整齣
然後我就覺得讓我
做到好事情的感覺
可是我自己在拿獎啊
那什麼我都沒感覺
很明顯我有不是
非常長的一段時間
到現在我都還不是很有把握
但是我自己的事情就比較
比如說我去玩團啊
這種就是我自己的事情
我就超開心
可是有很多那種
外在成就肯定的事情
我會必須要用一整套去完成
我的那個肯定
所以這就代表著我們自己
想要的那一個肯定
有一套我們自己的劇本
哦
然後這套劇本他有演員
我們一定會把某些演員放進來
那一套劇本就叫做
比如說有些人一輩子
都想要爸爸的肯定
可是爸爸不肯定他
然後呢他很難放下這件事
所以他的劇本就是
我做到很棒的事情
可是我爸爸不肯定我
然後我很生氣
我覺得到底我要做到什麼程度
你才會肯定我
這個劇本聽起來好像很有道理
演員這裡面有的
對象就是我、我爸
然後他不肯定我以及成就
這個東西聽起來很正常
可是話說回來
如果這件事情是你想做的事情
你爸爸在他的
世界跟價值觀裡面
他不能理解你的世界跟價值觀
在意的事情
這就是你長大的過程
那為什麼這件事情對你來說
你需要爸爸肯定那麼重要
那也代表你的劇本當中
你永遠是你爸爸的兒子
你跟你爸爸是不平等的
也就是說我覺得這也是我們在
現在很常在講個體話
在講長大
我覺得這是長大的
過程中最困難的
那就是比如說我
今天一輩子都覺得
我要讓我自己感覺到滿意
讓我有安全感的方式
是讓我媽媽獲得肯定
結果今天我覺得不行
我要做我自己想要做的
所以我要把這件事情放下了
你會先有一段時間覺得眼前
伸手不見五指
嗯你以前
賴以為生的那一個標準
你現在要長大
你要把這些東西放掉
你要建立你自己的標準
可是你還沒建立的時候
你會覺得很慌
完蛋我以前只要
做到這樣就OK了
就一百分了
現在沒有現在那些東西都不對
那你怎麼辦
然後很多人要經歷這個模糊
很恐怖他就會退回去
他就退回去
再去跟他爸爸要
就算沒要到標準在那裡
我知道我要往哪邊努力嘛
就舒服
就是比如說好今天跟完全理解
賴律師媽媽說你
不用再要他們了
那我不要他們我要什麼
對要什麼要要面對自己
我要什麼我有什麼
我能成為什麼 哇賽好可怕
那我還是跟他們要好了
反正追一輩子如果他們沒給我
那就是他們的錯嗎
我告訴你
周慕姿根本應該
寫我這本書的序
因為他幾乎把我
後面都寫講完了
你真的是講我
哪裡看你忙成這樣
都怕你又瘦下去了
對我太好了
我沒有真的你太厲害
因為我其實後面
後半段就在講你這件事
你知道然後呢
然後呢
然後的時候
我是用對抗這兩個字來講
就是說你要反抗那個
知道你不要去做那一塊事情的
那個那個反抗
所以我有一個地方在講說
最難的就是你知道不要這樣做
但是你又一直往那邊做
所以你就不要做
你要這樣做的事情
就是譬如你想吃鹹酥雞
你叫你現在不要吃
在聖誕節的時候
對
那最難的是這件事
所以剛好慕姿講到
我提到有一段是講反抗了
就對抗也好反抗也好
也就是說在這一塊
你知道那個紅蘆蔔
其實是一個是一個幻覺
因為不是再也不是
這麼一件事的時候
你在要怎麼往前走的那一刻的
那個懸浮期啦
我們就是在那邊擺擺蕩蕩的
那那時候會破壞你原先的秩序
我本來覺得我爸媽
對我笑一個說
哎呀周慕姿
你周慕姿的媽媽
你真的他你女兒真的好棒哦
怎麼樣怎麼樣
好那個可能完成那個儀式
這一件事情其實
不應該成立的
對你要講
不一是叫不應該
而是說他可能是過去的事情了
那是小時候的周慕姿不再是
40歲的周慕姿了
所以40歲的周慕姿已經說
你不用再過15歲
的周慕姿這種
青少年期許得一個母親的喜悅
這件事你不需要的時候
那你就會
知道這個事情但是你脫離不了
那因為回到那個原點
你的快樂的標準還是最簡單
因為你習慣他40年了嘛
對不對對
所以你要脫鉤對抗
然後到你長大這一段
你就是在那邊飄來飄去
再找回自己
新的秩序
然後再往下走
在move on
我覺得那個改變就是
真的是長大的過程
真的
但是我我覺得像
賴律師剛講那個東西
我覺得他真的是
我們好像會覺得說
知道
就是我知道之後
然後我會去對抗
然後我會想要不要再按照
這樣的方式去走
可是有時候很不容易
因為
挫折的時候會走回回頭路
我我開個玩笑講就是
比如說像我我從小
有一個生存策略
因為我媽媽既然
對我要求這麼高
有些人是會盡力做到
我的個性是我會留一手
哦 就是那種會留一手的人
留一手的原因就是因為
我也不甘心
我也不甘心說
但其實就是因為
你會很沒有安全感
因為你會很需要
其實我媽不一定有這樣講
可是他可能也會跟我分享啊
他小時候誰看不起他
誰覺得他不好
然後因為我的關係
他就不會被看不起
就是那不是直接講的
但是那是很隱晦的東西
然後有時候他可能會講
親戚間怎麼樣怎麼樣
可是因為我成績很好
所以大家對他就基本來說會
有一些尊重
那我
我下一次就會覺得說
好像我的表現就會決定
你過得好不好
可是我也不甘心啊
因為我會覺得說
哦 乾我屁事
因為有時候有時候
也會覺得為什麼
我要做到這個程度
所以對我來說
我就會去練習做一件事就是
做到什麼程度
你就會被大家看得起
我只做到那裡
哦
做到哪個程度
比如說我媽跟我說
啊我們很窮
我們念私立學校很辛苦啊
你要拿獎學金
那我就會問做到什麼程度
你付的錢
我就只做到那裡
嗯
所以一個一個學期付
五六千塊行不行
行我就只考到
可以拿到一萬八獎學金的地方
然後如果做到這樣
你會不會被尊敬
會不會被看得起
可以那我們就只做到這裡
我就會很習慣
用這樣的方式去保有
我的自我
嗯
可是他也會變成一個
很可怕的東西就是
他變成一個習慣
嗯
因為我是為了別人努力
所以我想要留一手
可是另外一個方面
我也很怕一件事
這是一個很暗的東西
那就是我很怕
如果今天
我真的盡全力
還沒有辦法讓你
得到很棒的肯定
那我的價值是不是就沒
哦
所以留一手不只是
為了保護我的自我
也為了保護我的自尊
讓我不用去面對
我最
我可能會有不夠的時候
然後我覺得這件事情
在我的人生中是一個很重複的
主題
然後就像剛剛賴律師說的
我們在長大過程中
我們會有一個一直重複的主題
在不停的經驗在
我們的關係裡面
在我們的生活裡面
在我們的生涯裡面
然後我自己這一次去
芬蘭演出的時候
我就發現樂團是
就是我有
我就會經驗到一個東西叫做
我在我心理師工作的時候
我常常可以感受到我留一手
我還是可以把事情做得很好
雖然我會過度努力
可是那是因為這個
東西是我的作品
我要做到一個程度
可是我不會逼自己每件事情
都要做到這樣
我很多事情我就是覺得
沒關係不用那麼好
不用那麼厲害
不用那麼紅
反正這樣啊
夠用夠用這樣就好了
很習慣用這樣的方式
那心理師這一塊是
發展的其實相對是比較穩定
可是樂團那邊就是
我覺得我很努力
他就是有一個限制
那當然有很多理由
可是在樂團那邊
我就會很明顯的
感受到自己的不足
然後我覺得這一個感受
對我很重要
怎麼說呢
因為我發現
在工作這件事情上
我不敢去面對那一個
自己如果盡力之後
會發生什麼事情
如果我還是做不夠好
會讓多少人失望
會讓多少照顧我的人
失望就像我在重複
我跟我媽媽一樣
可是我在樂團這件事情
他真的是很自我的事情
所以我表現得好
表現得不好都是我的
因為這是我選的
我媽一點都沒
他也沒不鼓勵
但是他就是隨便你的這種狀況
他也沒什麼
就是我去芬蘭表演這件事
我也沒什麼跟他分享
我去那邊怎麼樣怎麼樣之類的
因為這就是我想要的
所以當這件事情好壞
都是我自己承擔的時候
要去面對那個不足的時候
雖然那個東西很
赤裸
可是我覺得很真實
會有活著的感覺
可是要去面對這件事情
對我們每個人來說
其實都是很不容易
因為如果
把樂團這件事情
只是當成我的名牌包
那有多好
周慕姿心理師順便有樂團
那我就可以過得很開心
是
可是當我有
但對我來說可能會是
如果我今天都已經這個年紀了
玩這個樂團
我還想做到什麼
我可以為自己做到什麼
當我有這個期待的時候
我就必須要去面對
我可能還必須要
就是我不夠
或是我還要去做的事情
然後那個赤裸性
卻不是我日常生活習慣的那個
那個劇本
就是我日常生活習慣劇本
就是我只要用七分的力
就可以做到十分的事情
然後就可以Pass過這一關
慕姿你真的是
我覺得你下一本書
就要出來了感覺
我知道
最近都會一直沒有辦法面對書
越沒寫越不敢寫
我覺得能夠這樣的分辨自己
生命歷程的人
就是說
我有一件事還蠻特別的
我想反饋慕姿的是
把人生看這麼明白
會不會很辛苦
譬如說有一天我
我們兩個一個共同
朋友叫做鄧惠文
鄧醫師
惠文他在
他有一次我印象很深刻的是
他在講一個文學作品的時候
然後有一個觀眾
朋友問他一句說
什麼狀況下我們
需要覺醒跟探索
他說如果你現在過很舒服
你就這樣就好
我也這麼覺得
真的這句話你認可
完全認可
就是我覺得真的沒有
每個議題都要處理
就是又不是要成仙
為什麼要處理那麼多議題
又不是要成聖
對啊你夠用就好了
就是生活夠用就好
對
可是我覺得剛才慕姿那一段
我想要反饋就是說
當我們擁有自由的時候
就是慕姿因為他很有天賦
我必須講
因為跟他一樣聰明
的孩子我看很多
其實比較平庸的人
比較沒那麼痛苦
原因是什麼
因為我選擇一個
我就照著走就好了
對不對
就如同我剛才我們在前一段
譬如講我媽媽
童養媳你就照著走農村社會
其實是挺漂亮的
大家也都聽你的
你是長女啊長媳不是很好
我意思說
在一個舒適圈待著
好好的你為什麼要去冒險
可是慕姿在我看到他就是冒險
他其實
他的冒險好幾段
他以前是一個
應該是國營單位的公務員
那時候還不算公務員
我們算因為我們是
外插單位
我們沒有那麼
我們沒有那麼幸運
有那個公務員的福利
但是我們做的公務員
的事情倒是真的
但他那個工作
你絕對沒有想過
跟現在到底有什麼關係
然後接下來他又到教職
對就當代理老師
代理老師
然後他這位小孩呢
就看到電視上覺得
我覺得當心理師不錯
代理老師是那個
當心理師之後
的事
所以我是先
先那個時候就是在
在那個
就是剛剛說那個
那個單位先做了五六年
有五六年
對有五六年
然後那時候又看電視
然後又自己覺得說
啊心理師
其實我那時候做心理師
真的是覺得
考慮到就是
也是考慮到未來
就是考慮到我
我那時候想
因為然後本來也有考慮律師
然後我問他還沒來
對我問我朋友
朋友說律師每天都要在
那個自己辦公室
那個新手律師
都要在辦公室迎接隔天的
就是日出
我說那我不要
就是因為我就是
我就是一個草莓族
沒有
律師真的很耗能
那個工作
然後
可是我要講的是說
教職也好
後來在
但是你學的是大傳
對一開始學的
對一開始的大學的時候
對對對
然後樂團也一直在唱
而且他唱的都是那種非主流的
而且是那種
很很難想像的那種
對我們來講是地下樂團的那種
Rock那種
然後甩頭那種
然後他的音樂非常的
你如果去看《大濛》的話
我覺得那個很大
應該主題需要
希望以後可以有機會
對我覺得
再紅一點
沒有 已經夠紅了
就是《大濛》那部電影
大概配上周慕姿的那個音樂
大概就
大家可以想像那個色彩
也就是說
因為慕姿是一個
很有機會的人
很有機會的人就是這樣
他天賦夠
所以他可以
他其實這部分像他爸爸
這些多才多藝
好
所以我會覺得
當一個人選擇開始自由的時候
就會背負很多的壓力
因為你開始在這個選擇當中
比別人要想更多
你不會再有舒適圈了
那你就得要去闖
闖蕩各種選擇下的冒險
那所以我們就
一條路就走到底就好了
但是你們就一直在冒險
我的看法是
我覺得你們比較是冒險者啦
但是其實回過頭來
賴律師
我們兩個人
會很談得來
因為賴律師其實在你的人生中
跟在你的職業中
你也算是一個冒險者
雖然說就是
律師是你當了很多年的事情
可是這中間你做了很多事
你其實一直在就是各種插花
各種無心插柳柳成陰
所以我覺得這個就是
我看起來在體制裡面
可是我在體制裡面
我還是要
闖個東西
因為我的個性是
我其實不太喜歡體制
我真的是一個
不太喜歡體制的人
所以我那種體制不留人
自有留人處
就是那種狀況不對
我就閃人
然後我就自己就是
劈一個山頭
然後就自己在裡面種田
然後就說
這就是我的地方
可是我覺得賴律師
很不容易的是
要在體制裡面做改變
那才是真正困難的事情
我覺得
我在寫這本書
尤其講不將就
那個是我滿大的一個劇本啦
對我就是剛才講的
如果重複的事情
大概就這件事了
就是說
當我自己當律師的時候
大家會覺得
你不像律師
或者說
你怎麼會唸法律系
或者你不像律師的時候
那我就會說
我告訴你我是可以的
我是可以的
然後那個時候的典型律師
你要走到非典型律師
你知道那個冒多大的險
那個年代更
那個年代真的
尤其都是中年男性
是律師的形象
真的真的
所以對一個女性
然後用一個比較
而且我那時候
還是刻意在媒體上
穿著女性的衣著
因為大家對律師的想像
是有一定的
一定的想像
那個叫品牌嘛
那你就要穿出一個女性的特質
我就是說女性的特質
為什麼不是律師
所以你就要開始創
可是你知道那個罵名更多
就是說
我們剛才回到
慕姿講的肯定
這件事情的時候
我是倒著做的
我沒有要你肯定
我就告訴你
這就是我
好那這就是我
那索然也會傷心
一直被射箭
到目前為止
因為慕姿也是有得過那一段
就是你什麼也沒做
就一直開始被射箭對不對
然後因為你做的樣子
對他們來講太危險
因為你在冒犯他們
對於一個律師的形象
制度的那個部分
或者是他的圖騰
你可以講圖騰
就是他們有他們既有的圖騰
你怎麼可以
離今叛道的做
離今叛道有沒有
我們剛才講的三代女性
都在做這件事
離今叛道
你怎麼可以離今叛道
所以當你的冒險
是一個離今叛道的行為的時候
社會大眾是害怕的
所以他得要攻擊你
對我的理解
他就攻擊你
怎麼可以不像律師
你怎麼可以如何又如何
那我覺得這件事情是在
我覺得長大的歷程當中
對我來講很重要
剛才慕姿講無心插柳柳成陰
就是我不斷的插花
因為我不斷的
告訴我自己的生命
底色是什麼是做自己
為什麼一個行業別
可以鎖住一個人的一輩子
就像慕姿想要做樂團
他也想要做到另外一個專業
你剛才在講不足
因為你想要去在那邊做足
但時間不夠
體力不夠
應該講是體力不夠
可是
本來就是有一些地方讓你不足
如果都足的話
我們哪來的前輩
哪來的進步
對不對
一定有讓我不足
所以不足反而是我的動力
我說永遠不夠不夠
譬如說
可能我做的不夠多
在性別議題上不夠多
所以現在很多那種
又回頭想要躺平的女性
回到阿嬤的年代
也是有
或者是我覺得可能
我在做兒少或家事議題不夠
我覺得永遠不夠都會是我的
一個動力就是怎麼樣
再往前
那時候我發現跟社會多好困難
你看我
我覺得一直跟社會多好
困難的原因是說
你們都會用一個
很僵化的
二元的對立的仇恨的方式
在爭取你們的話語權跟力量
可是一個話語的力量
為什麼一定要用憎恨
因此我就會開始
慕姿也跟我一樣
就寫書
去講我在想什麼
因為那種媒體語言對我來講
是很困難的
我自己非常困難
那個我只要去上一個
大家都不太知道
我上電視節目
每次回來都會難過兩三天
完全可以理解
所以我才覺得你很厲害
你有沒有發現後來我都不太上
因為周慕姿也是如此
又落跑了
那種文化
那種產業文化
慕姿跟我都有點難受
但是我才說我超佩服你
你一邊難受
但是你有你想做的事情
所以你還是會堅持去
我就是我胸無大志
沒有
慕姿用更聰明的方法
我覺得你用了聰明方法在對話
所以我覺得
在那個難處當中
我覺得我永遠要
去找到一個空間
所以有寫作
當然有做一些影視作品
有時候寫書
我那時候一直跟周慕姿講
請你寫小說
我不是講八百遍
小說真的要靜下心來
我覺得這時代
這就是很多事情插進來
那個沒有辦法靜下心來
結果好難
我大概最接近的嘗試
就是過度努力
最接近的嘗試
所以我會覺得說
在做各種的一個嘗試當中
其實我只是想要回到一個
真實的賴芳玉
而不是賴律師
因為賴律師其實本身就
涵蓋了一個律師該有的樣子
他正在定義我這個人
大家會知道我叫賴律師
其實不太記得我叫賴芳玉
因此我必須要在
很多的嘗試當中
還原我自己的本色是什麼
這個是我對自己的叛逆
我想這個應該是
我不斷的在各個取向當中
大概都一直找到這個點去切入
所以有時候有人都說
這個案子你為什麼要接
我經常被攻擊這句話
賴芳玉一定是怎麼樣
大家對我有很多的既有的想像
可是對我而言
我為什麼要因為你們的定義
而改變了我的決定跟選擇
所以回來我要講一件事
當一個像慕慕姿有天賦的人
他的選擇開始自由的時候
某個背後就叫承擔
那個承擔的後面你就覺得不足
我跟你講我八百遍
大概都在想這件事情
那個不足
因為我老覺得自己是不夠的
你在一個被律師圈
認可的律師當中
我不足
因為以他們標準我還真不足
我只是長大到覺得是榮耀而已
我跟你們不一樣
就是我最大的榮耀
我做出我自己賴芳玉三個字
這個承擔的背後
那個不足的時候
經常讓我處在一個糾結當中
我舉在另外一個例子
我有一次跟精神科醫師在聊
我的一個朋友林醫師
我就說這些人
這麼糟糕的做我不認可的行為
就是我們毀三觀的事情
可是他是很
就是他的成就非常好
他的事業好像也挺好的
然後我就會講一個
不甘心就憑什麼
我有一個地方就是憑什麼
我相信很多人你在心裡想
一定很多事讓你覺得憑什麼
然後我看到我的矛盾點
我應該講這位醫生
看到我的矛盾點
他說賴芳玉這樣好不好
現在這些我們的時候做協會
做兒少的工作
這些事情都讓我們來做
你去做賺錢的事沒問題
你不用糾結了
我那一棒馬上被打醒
就是說是的
我正在做的這個選擇
我為什麼對這個
選擇不幸不甘情不願
所以我必須要為我的選擇
而承擔這一件事情
是我長大的地方
然後做對的選擇
經常是不舒服的
對
真的很不舒服
賴律師你真的是走過的人
所以你才會講得這麼深
因為這個東西是
這個是很真實的
就是像我剛剛說的
就是說包含剛剛就是
賴律師有在講媽媽的那個部分
他又就是選擇他自己
想要自由戀愛的部分
可是他還是想要回過頭
來得到家庭的肯定
我覺得很多
我不知道男性
會不會有這個意識
我在想一定也有一些
男性有這樣的議題
但是我覺得有很多女性
很明顯有這樣的議題
就是我既想做自己
我又想要獲得世俗的那個
標準的肯定
我完全理解那個狀況
然後因為我自己在很年輕
也不是也沒有多年輕
就是我開始念諮商
然後我有跟
我忘記我有沒有跟
賴律師講過這件事
因為我們兩個很多
很類似的經驗
所以我那時候就是
剛開始才剛開始
好像也還沒出書吧
然後就是剛好跟一些前輩們
就聽他們講說
他們跟什麼地方合作
怎樣怎樣怎樣
然後我記得我那個時候都覺得
我那時候就突然有一種
覺得很不舒服的感覺
不是生氣他們
也不像是嫉妒
我就比較像是覺得自己很爛
的那個感覺
然後我就有那種很大的羞愧感
然後我記得那一天
我就覺得 等一下周慕姿你怪怪的
我就去走了大安森林公園
那個是一個午後
就吃完午飯
然後下午
然後我就去走大安森林公園
我就一直問我自己我怎麼了
我就發現他們說的那些東西
我好像覺得
我不是跟他們一樣
在這個時候有這些東西
我是不夠努力的
我是不夠好的
我表現是不夠的
可是我就回過頭來想
那我真的想要這些東西嗎
我真的很想要跟這些單位合作
我真的很想要變得很紅
我真的很想要上很多電視
我真的很想要
然後我發現裡面有一些東西
我不一定這麼想要
然後我就開始想
可是別人的標準如果是這樣
我的標準是這樣
那我要選哪一個
我什麼時候要選哪一個
大家可能就會覺得說
周慕姿心理師一定就是
我選自己的標準
沒有 我跟你講
錢還是很重要
一個朋友
我那時候的確就想說好
但是因為我知道我的個性
我的個性就是
我其實很容易覺得
我自己這條路就對了
我其實是一個滿叛逆
你越有跟我講什麼東西
好我越不想做
所以我就跟自己說
這本來就是我的弱點
那我就先做做看
大家都說好的
然後看看這過程
我的感覺是什麼
然後我自己想做的
我也還是做
我們就來看看
最後我感覺哪一個
我做起來比較舒服比較輕鬆
所以後來那時候
賴律師你還記不記得
2017年
什麼節目邀我我都去
那個時候我節目超多
然後還有什麼訪談
找我 天下還訪了我四頁
然後到現在
影片都一直出來
那時候我胖的要命
那2017年我就是
帶狀節目什麼
我就是都上
我覺得那時候
就是過度努力的周慕姿
還有他的演講那個場次
那時候場次
就是誰邀我我都去
不是人可以過
對那時候誰邀我我都去
然後我就是經歷了一年
我也是有一點過度
我就是讓自己
整個就都走完之後
我就發現我很清楚
什麼東西我要
什麼東西我不行
然後我覺得
在那一個選擇的時候
開始選擇
不要有那麼多
媒體曝光的時候
非常非常的掙扎
因為那時候
我會介紹其他人去
然後有時候介紹
其他人去對其他人來說
可能會是一個
他們是很喜歡的
因為他們喜歡
他們才會答應
然後當他們很喜歡
他們答應了
然後也許有一些曝光
或是我在
我記得剛開始的時候
我也還是會有那個猶豫說
怎麼辦
我會不會被人家
覺得大頭症
我會不會推掉的一些
其實是很好的機會
別人覺得要珍惜的
我沒有珍惜
然後也會有這些焦慮在
所以我覺得
聽賴律師
剛才講那個東西
我好有感覺
就是明明我知道
那不一定是我想要的路
可是我又很害怕
會不會我漏掉什麼
因為畢竟能做到什麼失
或多或少
還是蠻能按照
這個社會的主流價值觀
去生活的
我老實說
所以當這個價值觀
對我們來說
用了那麼久
今天要把它直接放下
然後完全用一個
新的價值觀去走
完全心裡
不會有任何的OS我覺得真的是
非常非常大的困難
要不焦慮真的很難
我覺得慕姿
他是一個
對不起
但我太想講他
因為我看著他長大
我也很想讓
大家去看到慕姿的
轉大人的歷程當中
他克服的東西
超過你們的想像
因為他一開始就很紅
可是我看到的慕姿
是這件事就是說
慕姿的歷程
跟我不太一樣
我是從
到電視節目
大家慢慢認識我
我是有一個緩衝期的
但周慕姿沒有
周慕姿很像
有一個藝人在講說
我把別人脫光
我的衣服的
那一個衣服
一件一件穿回來
有點像
大家一定不明白
這句話
因為慕姿他是爆紅
他其實那時候
第一本書
《情緒勒索》
大家都知道了這本書
他沒有預期這麼紅
絕對沒有
如果要有預期的話
這個四個字
在那個時候
大家是陌生
而且不太認同
不是主流的書名
不是
並不是
但是慕姿選擇
這四個字
是完全你取的
也不是 是出版社
因為那時候
其實嚴格來說
就是因為這本書
就是在講這個現象
然後我們那時候
有在說
要不要取一個別的書名
什麼
然後討論就說
那就直接用這個現象
取名就好
所以就用這個現象
然後所以一開始
我就講說
這個現象是國外的
哪一個學者出來的
有有
他都有說
但是後面太流行的
大家都忘了他講過
對 然後大家就會說
你就是為了紅
所以你故意要
用這個名字去取
我覺得慕姿
在那一段時間
我看到他
爆紅之後
通常爆紅是
應該很開心
沒有他的壓力
隨之而來
因為他沒有
去應對過
社會大眾的經驗過
因為你沒走過媒體
那是你第一次
對 好可怕
他是一個
從很素人的方式
寫書 爆紅
所以突然要去面對
社會大眾如何看到
一個像公眾人物般的
人這一件事情
那個就很像你中了樂透
怎麼樣過日子
很困難是一樣的
那我覺得慕姿
在這一路走來
我已經幾年了
2017到現在
所以也八年了
八年
這八年
你看到慕姿的努力
其實他每一個
肯定都是真的
他努力來
他沒有用一些
什麼特別的
他就是用他的實力
一個一個累積回來
包括他的職場說
你知道我的多少
家事案件
每次我問說
你的諮商師是誰
都是他們事務所
他們諮商所的
大家做的好
就表示說
他連中生代都做了
因為以前慕姿
都以為是小朋友的
但是沒有他
他中生代
包括很困難
棘手的婚姻
親子議題
都有在協助
所以我就說
在這個歷程當中
如何當你做
你自己的選擇
而必須要去承擔
這些風風雨雨的過程當中
還能夠繼續走下去
這不是一般人做得到
而且你要挺住
這個是我的選擇
但其實我覺得
回過頭來
就像賴律師說的
因為畢竟在
你的經驗當中
你可能會說
你之前是慢慢累積上來
但話說回來
你也是累積了
一個很大的能量 可是後來你就決定
轉去做協會
然後還有包含你這個
書裡面在談的很多東西
我發現
賴律師除了法律的東西之外
其實花了很多時間
去理解哲學
還有心理諮商
甚至榮格的很多東西
我那時候其實就覺得
對於家事
就是婚姻
還有關係之間的東西
賴律師很有愛
然後對於
很多女性的一些環境
甚至很多男性的
環境
賴律師也非常非常的重視
因為有些人就是
如果是比較重視
性別文化或是女權
然後假設又是女性
有很多人就會說
我知道男性也很辛苦
但是我比較重視女性
就是他要選個立場
這完全可以理解
可是我覺得賴律師
比較特別的地方是
對於男性的困境
賴律師也很重視
所以這本書裡面
其實也有提到
就是男性在婚姻
跟家事發生
這種婚姻必須要分開
然後要拿權利的時候
拿孩子的監護權的困難
還有就是表達情緒的困難
還有遇到婆媳問題的困難
然後我那時候印象就很深刻
書裡面有一個例子
就是在講一個男生
就是在講洗碗
因為之前也有一篇
那個洗碗文
然後被大家就是罵得要命
然後他那個
賴律師就是非常直接的
很誠懇的把他的那個
分享寫出來就是
他分享了就是說
他在洗碗的時候
就是會覺得自己很可憐
之類的
賴律師你可以分享一下
這個故事
我一定要分享
是因為要跟慕姿對話這個
我寫這一則訪談的時候
其實是在那個
筆戰的那個網友的文
還更前面
那我想這個對話
我覺得對聽眾應該
會很有幫助
好
這是一個中年男性
那因為我在探索的是
這個中年男性的心態
那這個中年男性
他結婚了
一二十年
所以到了中年
那也有了孩子
有他很喜歡的女兒等等
那這個
他有一陣子
就是他在諮商
他到處在諮商
那我就問他說
你遇到什麼困難
會一直需要諮商
第一個我先講
非常好
男性願意諮商
是一個非常好的事情
而且他講出來也非常好
那麼但是我就問他的困境
他說我跟我太太卡住了
我說卡住是什麼
他說我太太說
我是一個大直男
不會讀空氣
我覺得Bingo
很多的男性
都有這個男性腳本
好
他覺得他做到一個就是負責
我剛才講選擇下面的承擔
跟負責是他對愛的腳本
他認為負責
就是他該做的事情
所以我說
你對愛是這樣想像
那我就問你說
那你對於那個傾聽
比如很心理學的用語
傾聽 陪伴
這些你的感覺
他覺得這是一個很扯的事情
為什麼這個
用一個傾聽跟陪伴
就可以取代一個男人
對待他老婆的一個方式
他其實沒有認同
所以你就會聽到
那個很不同的一個概念
好
那他就繼續我說
那你可以不要再跟我分享
你卡住了什麼
他說 他就舉了一個例子
他說 我老婆叫我洗碗
我這時候你很想翻白眼
洗碗為什麼要讓你卡住
到底能卡住什麼
對不對
很多人會接一句說
你買個洗碗機就好
不是 這不是洗碗機的事情
它是洗碗的事情
誰洗碗的事情
他說
賴律師我知道你會糾正我什麼
我知道在性別平等下
洗碗是應該的
好
但我不明白
這為什麼是一個題目
就是
老婆你洗個碗就好
為什麼要為這件事情生氣呢
然後我說那你怎麼做
他說 我知道呀
我就去洗碗
事情就解決啦
OK
我說那我可以再問你
你為什麼覺得你
你洗碗的感覺是什麼
他說
我覺得我委屈
我說 你洗碗會委屈
又想翻白眼
他這回答一整個會讓
很多女性翻白眼
這時候就要問
那你委屈了什麼
他說
他
我媽媽從小就告訴我
男人不能進廚房
洗碗就很沒用
我說 洗碗很沒用
所以你的感受是
他說
洗碗讓我覺得
他真的是
很誠實的面對我
他就說
我覺得我洗碗
是一個很沒有用的人
然後呢
沒有爸爸好
他回答說
我沒有我爸爸好
我沒有用的時候
我完全沒辦法連結到
洗碗到底跟這個
這麼大的議題
有什麼關係
他說
因為
媽媽呢
有這樣交代我
然後我爸爸也不用洗碗
可是為什麼
我走入了
我的婚姻
我得要洗碗
而且我的
太太叫我洗碗
我還得要洗碗
他說他不太能夠
去
感受到這件事情的重要性
以及為什麼一定要這麼處理
然後我接下來問他說
那你到媽媽家
會洗碗嗎
他說我就不洗
我跟我太太先約好
然後到媽媽家
我就不洗
至少不要讓我媽媽難過
我說
是不知道你媽媽難過
所以我說
那你洗碗這件事情
有沒有可能是覺得
你背叛的媽媽呢
有沒有可能是這個感覺
就是
因為媽媽交代你
不可以做事情
然後你卻去做
你覺得你好像在做錯的事情
可是你又為了
你老婆
所以你又很委屈的
去做了一個
你媽媽交代
你不能做的事情
我覺得他在那邊
是點頭的
然後呢
我又開始問他一個
又會讓我翻白眼了
你們一定知道
你會翻白眼的點
如果不懂
一定要聽這一集
我說
那你當時
因為我講
我講愛這件事情的時候
我說你為什麼
會愛你老婆
而且選擇
跟他走一輩子的路
因為你對愛
是認為是一個
承擔跟負責的話
那表示你願意
為這個女人
承諾了一輩子的負責
那這件事情
你為什麼選擇的是他
好
他的白目又讓你翻了
他說因為他像我媽媽
很真很艱難
我覺得這個東西
很有趣
就是當男生
真的很誠實的
面對這件事情之後
我的太太
給我很大的安全感
有時候
因為我跟我的媽媽關係
很好
所以她給我的感覺
我有被照顧的感覺
我有在她旁邊
很安全的感覺
這個東西
可能跟我媽媽
給我的很像
可是另外一方面
我又很怕人家覺得
我是媽寶
因為這樣子
就代表我很媽寶
然後我太太
說不定也會說我很媽寶
對
這一個東西很有趣
就是就像剛剛賴律師說的
他是不是覺得
媽媽有一個價值觀
他如果沒有按照
這個價值觀生活
他好像背叛了他媽媽
另外也有一個部分
那個感覺很強烈的是
我媽媽
讓我自己
建立了一個新的家庭
結果在這個新的家庭
我委屈了
所以今天
我是帶著一個小孩的心
你看媽媽
就是其實跟我有點像
就是我是帶著一個小孩心
你看媽媽
你看我現在過得很好
現在這一個人
他把我照顧得很好
所以你不用擔心
可是現在
我居然需要洗碗
我既不夠有男子氣概
我也委屈
我覺得這個東西就是
所謂媽不媽寶這件事情
我覺得最困難的地方就是
在台灣的文化
跟家庭教育裡面
我們其實
沒有很習慣讓孩子長大
是真的長大
同意
就是父母
你不管在外面
呼風喚雨
回到家你就是個小孩
就是那個
就最愛講的這件事情
就是他們家
三個小孩都是醫生
然後回去跟爸媽講
說你要怎麼
就專業上
他們就是很厲害
所以你要怎麼樣
什麼東西怎麼樣
他們就會說
我跟你講
我們那個什麼
我們那個什麼鄰居
那個什麼朋友
他講什麼東西
我跟你講這個我知道
你不用管
這個我曉得
然後他們就想說
哇塞
我們三個專業的
比不上那個隔壁鄰居
還是什麼
而且我永遠沒辦法扭轉
你的價值觀
因為在跟你們的關係裡面
你們永遠都是
全能正確的爸媽
我們永遠是小孩
所以我們永遠是
在觀念上
我們是不平等的
是不能就是
不能互相交流的
所以我對於你的價值觀
我只有兩個選擇
一個就是贏人
一個就是接手
贏人就是我不認同
但是我也沒辦法改變你
所以我只好
再跟你在一起的時候
我得用你的價值觀
要不就是跟這位先生一樣
他就是用他媽媽的
價值觀去過生活
所以對他來說
他雖然知道
正現在主流價值觀是什麼
可是他從來沒有去思考過
我已經長這麼大了
爸爸媽媽他們的這個價值觀
是我的價值觀嗎
還是我把他們的價值觀
吃進去變成我的
我從來沒有思考過這個價值觀
對我的意義是什麼
我覺得對於很多人說
覺察到底為什麼很重要
我覺得就是在這種事情
就是這個東西對
你的意義是什麼
他對你的影響是什麼
他會因為這樣子
改變你的多少決定
然後我們一旦沒有辦法去
意識這件事情
我們非常難做選擇
我們的那些委屈
看起來都是真的
但也是假的
旁邊的人就會覺得為什麼
然後你又說不清楚
因為你並不曉得這個價值觀
原來影響你如此深遠
而對你來說
一直跟著你爸爸
媽媽的價值觀走
是一個很有安全感的事情
就是我們剛剛說的
不然你又要重新開始
一個新的價值觀
所以我在跟慕姿
聊到這一段的時候
我就感受到一個很深刻的
就是有沒有可能你長大之後
其實包括我的母親
還在在尋求父母的認可
86歲還在尋求
原生家庭的認可
這件事情他還是沒有長大
對我覺得最難的地方真的是
我必須要誠實去面對
會不會我跟我爸媽
就算感情再好
我們想要再親密
我們各自都是不同的人
我覺得長大最痛苦的地方
其實是這件事
就是我們沒辦法融合
我們會有想法不一樣的事之後
我們會有事情不一樣
就是看法不一樣
我們會有很愛但決定選擇
完全不同的時候
可是我們能抱有這樣的自由
建立一個新的關係
而不是只有那種
你一定要認同我
我一定要認同你
我覺得那個東西是
我覺得那個東西是滿難的
是很多人都會覺得
我覺得有很多年輕的小孩
也會這樣
他們就會說
我的父母他們都不支持我
我也會遇到一些這樣的孩子
會覺得說我有想做什麼事情
可是我父母不支持我
然後他們就會情緒勒索我
我說好那我先問一個問題
如果你要做那件事情
連父母不支持你
對你的影響是什麼
會不會真的讓你不能做這件事
有些當然很誇張
情緒勒索到很誇張
可是有很多其實是
他們就是口頭上不願意
但是其實你去做他也拿你
他不能把你綁起來或怎麼樣
然後我就覺得這件事情很有趣
我就會說那這件事情很有趣
因為代表你也
還沒有準備好長大
因為如果今天你做每件事情
都要有人支持你
你才可以做
代表你還沒有準備好
成為支持你自己的那個人
我覺得超棒的
我覺得從母子這邊
我得到一個最大的體悟
不管是我剛才講的那位中年男子
或者是媽媽的故事
我覺得有一個地方就是
慕姿在很早期在跟我們講
華人的親密關係是模糊界限
而這個模糊界限
在幾年之後的慕姿現在告訴我
我們認為這種親密關係
無論是親子或伴侶關係
都會認為要互相認同
我們才是在一起的
我們才是一家人的
我們才是伴侶
也就是說有沒有一個
長大的一個色調式
我認為你的
主體性跟我的主體性
同樣要被尊重
我沒有需要你來認同
我來認同
但我尊重互相尊重
而我們的關係你也要很勇敢的
你要應該講要很自信的
我們的關係
並不會因此而破碎
真的
那就是你講得太好了
真的我覺得你講到主體性
這個東西真的太好了
因為代表著我們兩個的關係
它可以容許不舒服的空間
那個不舒服就是
我們兩個有時候會意見不合
我一直都覺得你好棒
你好棒你理想化你
可是有一天我長大了
我會突然發現
有一些東西你跟我做的不一樣
每一個人都會有選擇
可是那個不一樣
不代表我們關係就要撕裂
也不代表為了要在一起
我們就一定要變得一樣
我們這一個關係
是可以有空間容許這個不一樣
這才是真正最棒的健康的關係
這才是理想跟健康的關係
沒錯
所以就變成是
很多父母跟小孩之間的困難
不是在於小孩
可不可以改變父母
而是你一提
你就要父母改變
這本來就很辛苦
可是你們的關係
你的意見跟他的意見
能不能很自在的出現
我覺得這件事情
就是我們在長大建立自我的
內在權威一個非常重要的關鍵
我覺得是真的是因為
大家不要覺得
賴律師這本書我真的非常
雖然我們剛剛好像
看起來沒在談書
但全部都在談書
都在書裡面的事
沒錯
因為我覺得賴律師講的這個書
完全都是在討論
我們在文化的幻想下
要怎麼樣慢慢的去學會
找到自己之餘
還能建立自己的內在權威
因為要按照自己的感受去走
可是不要那麼害怕
然後慢慢去試錯
然後去懷疑
去焦慮
然後去慢慢走向自己的路
那個真的是很需要練習
然後就包含剛剛講的這個男生
或者是說
在律師裡面還有一個例子
是一個女生就會
有一個女生就說
因為他婆婆就會講說
媳婦就應該要洗碗
然後所以他就覺得
他就只好洗碗
那他可能就會進入
一個受害者劇本
就是因為你們要我洗碗
我不得不做
可是其實你會有一個選擇
就是你婆婆會想要你洗碗
那是他的文化
你可以告訴他說
可是我不是這樣想
我不是這樣覺得
大家可能會覺得
這件事情很困難
但我個人真的經驗過重視
但是我經驗過之後
我發現對方
不見得完全不能接受
就是我覺得
你要越能夠長大跟
建立你的主體性
就是你個人的想法跟
你想要做什麼的東西
是可以自在地表述出來
然後你願意去表述
你要保護你自己這個部分
你敢保護你自己這個部分
你就會慢慢越長越大
然後這件事情是很大的挑戰
而我覺得
戴律師的這本書完全讓我
就是試著可以分享
這一個想法
我覺得這本書真的太讚了
就是大家真的要去看一下
謝謝慕姿
我覺得我終於知道
為什麼慕姿叫放心說
這個詞
因為沒有
在關係裡面
如何能夠互相有自己的主體性
放心的說出自己真實的話
我終於搞懂你
為什麼用放心說這個
因為它確實在關係很重要
因為你不需要
因為要去附和對方
或討好對方
而不能說
然後壓抑而自己
然後就離自己越來越遠
我都開始不認識自己了
反而是要回到這裡
然後就會很委屈
對 然後你也不用
因為不能說出來
而要逃離它
你不需要
對 真的
所以有時候我覺得
我覺得這節目很棒
我覺得賴律師你來真的很棒
因為剛剛講的那個
在關係裡面
有時候很難
你就是要附和
你要把它留著
或是你要逃離
這個剛好賴律師的書裡面
也有提到
有個例子也是這樣
我覺得
我覺得這個這本書
我非常非常推薦是因為
特別是如果你對於婚姻
對於你自己的性別
你有一些想法
我覺得非常鼓勵
你看戴律師的書
戴律師的寫法
跟我是很不一樣
對 非常不一樣
因為我說一句實話
雖然賴律師會說
我看起來好像很不像律師
但是那個寫法
你就會覺得
賴律師真的是律師
真的對不對
就是我覺得是很感情的
可是又很客觀真實
就是不是你想像什麼
很激湯那種
沒有 沒有
討論很多哲學
社會制度
我們文化影響
還有很多例子
所以非常容易看
可是又會讓你想到很多東西
所以我那時候看
我看前面幾個例子
我就覺得完蛋了
我們這集應該會錄三個小時
真的嗎
所以我今天就想說
那我們就
你看我們只聊兩個
我剛剛跟你提好幾個
我們後來只聊兩個
對 只聊兩個
對 大家如果覺得說
蛤
老師你還有想到很多個
賴律師書裡面還有很多
我想要再聽
留言好不好
留言我們就再找賴律師
留言夠多
我再找賴律師來錄影
我就找了機會
來跟慕姿聊天
真的很讚
我覺得我很喜歡
跟賴律師聊天
因為我們在很多性別
然後社會制度
然後還有一些
對人的一些觀察
常常會有很多
不同角度
然後很有共鳴的地方
我覺得慕姿夠敏感
也夠聰明
賴律師你也是
我在看的時候
我真的覺得
哇 這個我沒想過
就是有一些東西
我真的會覺得
這個我沒想過
這個好有道理
就是我覺得有時候
我們在人生中
我們常常現在
很喜歡講覺察覺察
就是我覺得這本書
還有就是
我們在講關係的
很多問題
最困難的地方
其實是關係
是一個照妖鏡
它會讓我們看到
很多我們想要藏起來
或是我們想要理想化自己
理想化別人的地方
可是我覺得
當我們今天
有機會真實的
面對自己
不管那個結果
是什麼
至少你跟你自己的關係
相對會近一些
確實
我覺得有一個
我有一個想問穆茲
如果講你
最展現你不勉強
不將就的地方
你會是什麼
不將就
我覺得在創作的時候
都是最接近
我自己的部分
對 比如說就是
我可能像演出
也是一種創作
然後我做課程
就是因為這個東西
就是我要做出來
然後可能
大家會有很多說
你可能至少要
什麼東西什麼東西
可是對我來說
就是我這個主題
我要讓大家
知道什麼東西
然後即使他可能
就是上次我開課
八個小時
我做了十五個小時
還是六個小時
然後就是
可能那個
大家團隊就會說
老師 我們這個
可能可以做兩堂
你還要繼續下去
我說對 對 對
我想一想
沒辦法
我覺得還是要放進去
然後
或者是說寫書的時候
可能就像親密恐懼
這一些
可能那時候
也會跟我討論說
不要寫那麼多
或是
但你可以猜兩本
那對我來說
我就會覺得
可是我這個概念
要講的東西是什麼
然後
那個東西
我比較不會覺得
是完美主義
不是因為我沒有覺察
不是這樣
我覺得是
因為我在做這件事情
是一方面是
當然痛苦開心
可是另外一方面
是我很清楚
為什麼我要這樣做
就是我有我很清楚的
目標 需求
然後做完
我就覺得我
就是這個作品
就完成了
那個舒適感
就是我沒有將就
或是沒有
遷就的去做完這件事情
那感覺是很爽的
你知道
慕姿每次講
他就會反映到
我這本書
我都已經忘記我那段
有沒有剪掉
我不知道時間上
能不能我講完這件事
就是說
在我們
因為我們有社會化的必要性
所以我們一定
會有很多地方很將就
必須講
我們得
得說有
因為你要生存
在這個社會生存
你說你在這個社會生存
又不管社會
沒有這件事
是 對不對
所以你會跟社會連結
所以你有很多
必須要將就的地方
但是我覺得
有一個地方
讓你不將就的時候
你就會覺得你
你靈魂還在
真的
對不對
律師律講得好好
對
就是靈魂還在
就是說你一定要
有保有這一塊
你才有辦法
好好地活下去活著
你才覺得你活著
對
就是不是行屍走肉
那個感覺就很像是我
那個樂團
那個就是不賣錢
然後
我就是講你那個
對
講你
可是像之前有人
有人跟我說
你為什麼不要唱一些
比較容易聽的
然後
我就心裡想說
哇塞
我玩樂團
我就是已經沒有
在賺錢
我就是想要做
我自己開心的
然後我還要考慮
大家怎麼樣才會買
然後我還要去
做那個東西
那我就做別的都好了
我幹嘛要做這個
真的
我真的講一個
昨天才
昨天我跟一個朋友
他是
也是做藝術的
他就最近跑去一個
日本
一個小鎮
啊
然後呢
他就做
他們真的在地創生
然後就是把那個
那個小鎮
就是在創
在創
有沒有看許我耀眼
或者去有風的地方
有沒有看到這個
我說
你為什麼要去做這個
這個看起來
就會賠
賠很多啊
他說
是不是這樣的
他說那個小鎮
他們盤了一個
百年的和服店
哇
你看
我跟你講
周慕姿眼睛
因為這也是他
會幹的事
我只好站好
然後呢
他就在那裡
盤了一個小鎮
然後在那邊
讓他如何
讓原來的那個和服
總之可以在那邊的
一些創意啊
包括創業
創意都有
然後我說
你這樣子
要砸多少錢
他說 他就算算
每年又要一百
然後先砸多少
我說那你為什麼
要這麼做
他說對
我為什麼這樣做
但是我說
可是我非常支持你
這麼做
為什麼
我說
你有沒有覺得我們人
活一輩子
活得很窮
我們都很省嘛
都要死的時候
才有錢
對不對 財富好像累積到錢
到底要留給誰
我說錢變成
你喜歡的樣子
不是很好嗎
真的
我覺得
我覺得我看到
就是類似
像我那時候說
我在做專輯
好最後要講完了
因為不然這一集
真的有夠長
就是我那時候
在做專輯的時候
因為我們混音
是送到瑞典
就是我非常喜歡
一個樂團的一個混音
很貴
雖然很貴
但那時候
我記得其中一首我很喜歡的歌
然後他
送回來的時候
我跟我先生兩個人
就一戴著耳機
然後聽 然後
那時候我們聽一聽
我們兩個就牽手
然後一邊聽我就開始哭
會哭
真的 我就覺得
怎麼這麼讚啊
就是那時候
那個感動度
我覺得那個東西
真的是沒有什麼東西
可以
整個靈魂被震動
講句實話
那個情緒勒索
就是連續上榜
第一名
那麼久我都沒有那麼感動
我覺得這個東西
是很難
就是那是很棒的事
就情緒勒索
賣得很棒
是很棒
就是我是很惜福的
這很棒
可是我的意思是
那個感動度是不一樣
或者是說有些人
就是聽Pakets
就是說我相信一定
會有很多人說
聽賴律師
跟賴律師這一集
受到很大的鼓舞啊啟發
我覺得那個人
可能這一輩子
要去尋找
內在權威的過程中
可以去追尋
屬於自己的意義感
我覺得這個東西
真的是很重要
真的很重要
我覺得這樣講
我們人生其實不容易
你一定會有很多的創傷
你甚至會有很多時刻是絕望
對
你一定會去經歷這些
你只要活著
就會去經歷這些
不如你意義的地方
可是如果你找回
剛才講的內在權威
跟自己的核心價值
你就會知道你活著
真的 那個不是什麼問題
那是過程
真的對不對
真的
我覺得
跟賴律師真的是聊不完
所以有各位朋友
如果你們今天
聽了我們講的東西
你覺得這本書
真的太讚了
請買回來看
然後買回來看之後
你看了裡面哪些主題
你覺得你超想要
再聽我跟賴律師講
請大家留言
留言就是夠多
我覺得
因為我還要給賴律師看
留言太少的話
我就不好意思請了
然後我就再找
賴律師來聊一集
因為我覺得真的是太讚了
謝謝 今天真的很感謝賴律師
謝謝慕姿
謝謝《不將就的勇氣》
我們會把書籍的資訊
放在我們的資訊欄
希望大家多多支持
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見
拜拜